elle est tombé dedans maman quand elle
était petite c'est le h pour la fille de
Don ché n ché au sommet de tout lesc
buffal
45nuit comme son prier album sushi parce
que le sushi c'est sexy qu'elle dit la
[Musique]
chérie
look
good
no you better watch don't M
me no my
[Musique]
manwe
h
es
[Musique]
with
yeah you money but you know never fun
when your shoes through and there's a
rble in me but you have to have St get a
go to sm put a girl on the corner so you
can make aitt a cri and inside it wasing
your but you had to surv when you lost
lost the race now you looking at me to
take up place who's looking good today
who's looking good in every no
St you watch mess with
me no money man my
love sweet that think
of we
hang we do the dan I give you love baby
man
nothing
ch fresh With
[Applaudissements]
Me
noting looking good hang with look good
in S looking good when it comes to de
looking good the State of Mind state of
mind don't look behind you St mind you
stay mind m I remind you
this what is he like what is he like
anyway man what do you expect the guys
[Musique]
man you're not
mean
weangff we do the every time we dance I
give you love not man make
ches With Me wind on my face S in my
ear for my eyes and you my mind as
iing down deep deeper into
your
My My Love
[Musique]
c'était Néné Cherry